este año es una huelga feminista la
manifestación de este ocho de marzo en
continuidad justamente con las
manifestaciones que ha tenido lugar
durante todo este año en contra de ese
proyecto de reforma del gobierno de
Manuel macron reforma de las
jubilaciones porque efectivamente son
las mujeres las más penalizadas por ese
proyecto Porque primero muchas de ellas
por ejemplo realizan labores que son
llamadas feminizadas zonas labores de
limpieza de ayuda a la persona que
normalmente realizan en negro quizás de
manera intermitente y por lo tanto no
van a tener esos años mínimos de
cotización para tener una pensión
completa y además porque las mujeres en
vista de los permisos de maternidad
predis natal también van a tener que
trabajar en promedio siete años más que
los hombres que también obviamente van a
tener que trabajar más si se aprueba
este proyecto porque se aumenta en dos
años la edad de jubilación Esa es la
reivindicación principal de este 8 de
marzo Pero hay muchas otras les invito a
escuchar algunas personas que
entrevistamos aquí en esta manifestación
en la Plaza de la república
pienso en todas las almas que hoy han
perdido su vida para reivindicar sus
derechos
y al hijo pienso mucho en las mujeres de
Irán en la actualidad todas esas mujeres
y hombres que se comprometieron por la
libertad y eso también aplica todas las
mujeres del mundo en Afganistán por
ejemplo también hay situaciones
dramáticas para las mujeres hay
problemas de feminicidios casi cada día
el derecho del aborto podría ser
cuestionado en cualquier momento hoy
pienso en todas las mujeres del mundo